hey how's it going
you enjoying the very stacked winter
2021 season
i sure am and i'm sure that even those
who aren't big anime fans are feeling
the hype
however i noticed that most of the hype
is coming from sequels
there's an attack on titan season going
on and the direction we promised
neverland decided to take left quite the
polarizing reception from the community
to say the least
that's why for today i won't be talking
about those shows
no aot no promise neverland not even any
re-zero
today is the new title that'll be taking
center stage as i rank the top 10
non-sequels that we've had this winter
2021 season
before starting i'd like to ask you to
subscribe to the channel it only takes
just a click
and it goes a long way in helping with
the youtube algorithm and
also it would just make me incredibly
happy now let's get the ball rolling on
today's list
we kick off things with something that
looks like an isakai
but isn't really so given its aesthetics
and long title i wouldn't blame you if
you thought it's another one of those
seasonal filler isakai titles but
suppose a kid from the last done
jumbooni's move to a starter town is
straight up fantasy i find the series
quite entertaining because of its
premise the premise might seem a bit
generic i mean you've got the dreamy
hero wanting to enroll as a soldier and
fight evil but lloyd our protagonist has
a lot of entertaining tricks up his
sleeve
one is that he's unaware of his power
and two is that he seemingly lacks
common sense in a lot of things so that
creates a lot of scenarios that can end
up being hit or miss depending on the
viewer but personally
i found some of them quite amusing
actually and i think that this is a show
whose enjoyment would derive from
whether you enjoy this kind of character
and setup or not
[Music]
you
[Music]
ninth on the list is one of my personal
favorites this season
bottom tier character tomozaki it's not
that long ago that origairu
ended and i think we're due for some
more self-help series that come with
their own dose of social commentary i'm
not claiming that this show can be
oregairu's spiritual successor it takes
a lot to carry on the latter's legacy
and despite the similarities domozaki
ain't the show to do it nevertheless i
still found this one to be so
entertaining mainly due to how
real it feels i know the way the
characters talk is a point of contention
for the show but i think it just makes
the whole experience feel more real the
show's point is depicting how high
schoolers with a lack of social skills
talk and interact with each other and
it's somewhat of an accurate social
commentary that's the whole point of the
show and the more our protagonist starts
leveling up in the real world the better
he starts talking and looking in
contrast to the hage protagonist look
that he rocked at the start
and besides that i find the banter and
the dynamics between aoi and fumia to be
just
amazing and fun to watch i found myself
thoroughly entertained but i acknowledge
that it's not a show for everyone
hence it's just number nine on this list
[Music]
coming in at number eight is redo of
[Music]
healer
[Music]
before the season started record redo of
gila the inter-species reviewers of the
season even before it aired
i knew controversy would follow it the
rest of the way i just knew it was going
to be the popcorn show of the season
and guess what i was absolutely correct
just look at the polarizing reception
the show's had they say that all kinds
of publicity is good for the most part
and i think that it's helped redo appeal
to climb up the ranks as one of the more
popular shows in the current season
controversy creates cash and i think the
redo of healer is the show that
encapsulates that if you're up for a
revenge story as well as some things
that push the boundaries of what can be
shown on japanese tv redo of healers
your pick some people argue that the
show is a satire of the revenge story
that's become popular these days and
whether you think of it as such is
something that i'd like to know in the
comment section
[Music]
moving on we have a more traditional
isakai so i'm a spider so what
reincarnated as a whatever's been on the
menu for
i've already forgotten it's been quite a
while since the isekai boom started and
it's got no end in sight
even though some may disagree i think
that it's not completely a bad thing
slime has been one of the better shows
of the recent years and we've had a
great slew of isakai one which will be
way up high on the list later as for
this spider isekai show i'd say that
it's somewhere in the middle of the pack
that's not a knock against it i think
that it's really enjoyable and a lot of
the enjoyment comes from the main
character kumoko
just has some of the wittiest dialogues
in modern isakai and she ends up being
quite the charismatic lead that people
would root for the cgi does leave a
little to be desired but
at least it's not an arifuretta or
overlord i think it should be fine
in a less snap season this show would be
able to stand out more and be a new [ __ ]
amongst anime fans
ready to get edgy high-rise invasion is
up next
[Music]
survival horror is a genre that's always
given me a much-needed dose of
adrenaline and high-rise invasion has
lived up to its expectations so far
being a reader of the manga i love how
the series looked after being adapted
into anime form it just looks so sleek
and professional that is until the heads
start exploding and the carnage begins
which at that point you just realize
what kind of series this is the sudo
isakai is a survival series that slowly
transitions into a battle shonen and i'm
all up for the change high rise invasion
was a series that made me binge manga
for hours due to how exciting it is
and i found myself doing the same for
the anime adaptation if you're up for
something that can keep you pumped
throughout the season high-rise invasion
is my pick for you do take note though
that the show can get quite squeamish
and violent at times so you better
prepare yourself for some really
gruesome deaths
but of course what's watching the best
anime from winter 2021 without prime
equipment
that's why i want to introduce to you
the sponsors of today's video
raycon if you're up for some top tier
sound quality while listening to some of
the best lines in anime or you just
really dig an opening or end
theme raycon is your best friend
wireless earphones for tip-top quality
while costing half the price
raicon and their whole gallery of
colored wireless earbuds have got your
back here
featuring over six hours of playtime
seamless bluetooth compatibility and
bass like no other
nothing comes closer to the experience
that these earbuds can give you you can
even refer to some celebrities such as
rapper snoop dogg
singer ray j boxer mike tyson and nba
star j.r smith whichever design or
pattern of earbuds you pick
raycon allows a 45-day free return
policy although it's not like you'll use
it given how great these earbuds are
click on the link on the description box
or go to buy raycon dot com slash vinnie
tube to get 15 percent off your raikon
purchase
a whole new world awaits and raycon is
here to help you take that next step
experience anime like never before only
with the best earbuds in town
[Music]
as we enter the halfway point we move on
with kemonojin it's no secret that i've
got a soft spot for the supernatural
action genre with jiu jitsu kaizen
sending shockwaves to the anime
community this season brought us another
one to add to the genre in kimono gin i
wouldn't say that i didn't anticipate
the show but kimono gn has been a
pleasant surprise in that it exceeded
the expectations that i had entering
this season the first thing that comes
into my mind is just how much it reminds
me of demon slayer the supernatural
fighting's there and the stylistic
choices in arta there as well it's a bit
underrated for it should be on the
seasonal charts kimono gn is a really
pretty looking show with such a strong
season on our hands i'm not surprised
that the show's getting slept on however
the show is a pretty good watch and it
does some fun things about the tropes
associated with the genre to be
enjoyable
in our fourth place is skate the
infiniti
[Music]
okay i've got a confession to make here
when i made the preseason preview video
i totally forgot about air gear turns
out there really was an anime about
skating way before but it still doesn't
change the fact the skating anime are
quite rare between that and maybe yuri
on ice skate the infinity looks to make
a mark on a rather unexplored genre of
anime and i think that it does so with a
lot of success the story is really fun
and while the show is not exactly the
most realistic sports anime out there i
mean
what is probably a handful of sports
anime and that's it i won't deny if you
feel that the show is quite generic
however despite all of that i found
skate the infinity to be so entertaining
that the fact that it's not something
revolutionary never really mattered at
all it's extremely stylish and has its
own swag if you get what i mean so it's
not hard to ignore those perceived flaws
because watching the show is just a fun
ride if you're up for something
entertaining to pass up your time and
prefer a more casual watch skate the
infinity could be a show to put on your
[Music]
radar
now here's something that i overlooked
completely before the season started i
didn't expect the series to blow up the
way it did but looking at it it's
undisputable that wonder egg priority
has become one of the series contenders
for anime of the season
why you ask well perhaps it's the
gorgeous visuals the strong
themes and the compelling story that
ties everything together wonder egg
priorities a drama that's become a
seasonal favorite of fans who'd prefer
to steer clear of isakai or the rom-com
genre it's the pick of the season for
people who want something profound out
of their anime and for the most part
it has delivered in a way it reminds me
a little bit of madoka magika you know
the magical girl-esque show that appears
light and colorful early on but then
starts delving into some deeper
psychological themes will it continue
its momentum and end up being anime of
the year at this rate you can share your
thoughts on it after checking a few
episodes out
i had a really hard time ranking the top
two series here i would say give it a
virtual tie
but we're not going to i decided to give
mushoku tensei the nod for second place
on the list
[Music]
you get all these expectations being
built up is it any good
will it blow me away will it be the one
shining beacon in this sea of a genre
with varying quality i'd say that
mushoku tensei passes those tests with
flying colours
you can see how the series has inspired
a whole generation of isakai
writers even now the pace can be a
little slow at times but the show's
delivered a masterclass when it comes to
the world building and character drama
it looks really fresh amongst its peers
and you can see the dedication given to
producing this adaptation it deserves
the praise that it gets
despite some controversies regarding the
perverted main character you can clearly
see the care that the studio gave the
show but then again with it being a show
that took
way longer to get produced than normal
than having a studio made to
specifically produce it for a long time
to come would you expect anything less
coming in on top as the best new anime
this winter 2021 is
horimia
[Music]
this series is one of the most
anticipated shows of the season even if
we include
sequels horomia is still somewhere up
there and after watching the fast-paced
anime adaptation i wasn't disappointed
one bit
the premise didn't seem anything too
special at first glance and it seemed to
be your usual feel-good
wholesome rom-com about how opposites
attract those who expected a
light-hearted rom-com have been
surprised at how well the series manages
to weave the light-hearted moments with
character drama that level of emotional
investment for the viewers is something
that you don't see with rom-coms too
often and it's a major reason why hora
mia has been so highly praised by the
fan base it also helps that cloverworks
which some of you may remember from
promise neverland
bunny girl senpai and fake grand order
continue their role with their crisp
visuals to complement the overall feel
of the show as a bonus the manga is
about to end at the time of this writing
putting to close one of the best school
romance series that i've
ever picked up it makes it just the
perfect time to release the anime now
doesn't it right
[Music]
so how does your list look then what are
your favorites among the new anime this
winter 2021 season don't forget to share
your thoughts in the comment section
below or while leaving a like and a
subscription also if you're enjoying the
channel and want to support it a patreon
link is in the description box feel free
to support the channel
it's been a great season and i'm really
looking forward to more we're heading to
an exciting finish to the season and i
hope that you have fun with it don't
forget to check out our sponsors raycon
experience anime like never before only
with the best earbuds in town i'll see
you next time
on vinnie tube
[Music]
[Music]
you